[Music]
Uh going to dive right in. No
introductions. Um if you want to follow
along, get out your VS Code. Uh some of
the things I'm showing are VS Code
insiders. Who's an Insiders user?
Anybody? Oh, I got to explain that. So,
insiders is our pre-release that's built
basically by whatever the bu the team
landed the day before. It's going to
release actually twice a day. Um, and it
has all the latest things we're working
on. VS Code otherwise released on a
monthly basis. The next release is
coming up next week on the 11th. So,
uh, who has done VIP coding?
Anybody? Some some who has negative
feelings about vibe coding.
Okay. Some uh so yeah it's it's we want
to fully give into the vibes in this
presentation. Uh it's going to be a lot
of screenshottable slides to bring home
to your team. So get your phones out
now. We're going to embrace exponentials
and forget that code even exists. How
Andre Kaparthy created that VIP coding
idea.
So VIP coding in itself and why it has
these negative connotations. that starts
in this fun chaos mode. I think it's
part of the journey what I'm presenting
looking at the clock in 13 minutes and
40 seconds is how we get to this other
side of professional zen vibes. And to
break it down a bit, this initial vibe
coding, what you see most people do on
YouTube when they work on websites and
ship them to production and then wonder
why everything is slowly falling apart
and their their bills go up. That's the
YOLO vibe coding and not meant to ship
to production. It's about speed, instant
gratification. There's creativity in
there and it's really about this fast
learning. Hopefully I can highlight
that. Then next uh and these are all
madeup terms. This is a ever evolving
space. You can find if you have better
words, please bring them to me. But
structured vibes brings guard rails to
how these things actually act. And if
you have an LM in this first space, it
will just do creative things. guard
rails added to uh and enter the state of
maintainability and balance it to bring
you some more sustainable code in the
end. YOLO vibes are not meant to be used
in the long term. Structured vibes are
what where you bring actually that
enterprise state in in the end that
somebody you feel comfortable handing it
over. And lastly, we have the spectriven
vibes where I think most of you probably
want to end up with. And that's where
vibes, the idea of vibe coding scales up
to large code bases with scale and
reliability and really that that
velocity of everybody feeling the vibes
and generating code, but in a generating
code in a way that that fits into the
codebase.
So quick yolo uh outliner. Um as
Kaparthy termed it, it's all about the
outcomes. You don't look at code, you
iterate using language. Best even talk
to the AI. Then auto accepting is really
part of it. You don't want to you talk
to the AI, you look at what it creates
and all the rest just lands. Um if it
ever goes wrong, you just reset
everything completely. You throw out the
code or you undo and you keep going. And
there is a place for YOLO coding. It's
not just weird weekend things. Is rapid
prototyping and proof of concept you
just want to explore. It's where
creativity really shines and you can
focus on the outcome and that's that's
the thing where VI coding really shines
and while you do it you can learn you
can try something in a Rust codebase
make a Rust game make a Rust Frogger try
a different stack make a neon flickering
Rust Frogger just and then look at the
code in the end like how do games work
actually in Rust have AI explain the
code back to you and lastly personal
projects is it where we see it most just
over the weekend my kids needed an app
to do X and we build it together and now
we have an app to do X and I'm not
shipping it to production but it's my
app
so we can do some demos I think the
easiest way to show it off u just open a
new VS code window this is my insiders
uh if you haven't done it oh I have an
update pending this is insiders so it's
every day something new I'm excited but
not updating now okay um in
so make sure you're in agent mode which
right now isn't the default. We're
working on that. Uh we don't see it. Oh,
same problem, I guess.
Auto sharing to
don't monitor
change
entire screen.
Tada. Okay, thank you. Um yeah, so let's
start with the don't care about the
code. And one way to do this is auto
approve. If you look at chat autoproof,
it's a with caveats. Cool option. Um,
and you can enable it also for, for
example, your workspace only. Uh, but
autoproof allows you to avoid all these
confirmation buttons that the chat
otherwise annoyingly throws at you while
you're trying to vibe. So, while we're
here, let's start. There's uh you see
this little microphone button down here
and that is built in to VS Code. It's
actually a local model. Nothing leaves
your machine and it's really uh it's a
great way to just chat with the AI. I
you can actually set it back that it
responds everything back to you. Let's
try it. Uh let's make our first app and
then go back to the slides because we
want to just make co-pilot wipe what we
ask for.
So um actually the shortcut is for me is
command I like that one. Let's make an
app for uh water hydration tracking in
react and bite. It should use material
UI and follow nice applelesque design
principles. So yeah thank you.
Okay and off it goes. So what what you
see now first is actually we have a
create new workspace tool which lets you
vip code um a little bit easier. It's
let's do just something just copilot
yeah the copilot agent mode it comes
with with that tool. So demo one two
whatever it's v coding so we don't care
about the code but it has to be
somewhere. Okay. Um now because we have
the repo or workspace it will just
continue and now it will actually just
see how it starts it off created react
workspace water hydration tracking app
material UI apps design it made a plan
in the background and now it shares the
high plan with us and it goes off so we
can go back to the slides and not care
about the code
uh mpm install mpm def. So I trust it
will do stuff
we used the
Yes. Yeah. So, this is using Cloudin 4,
which I I found really good at um UI. I
actually ran the same demo with
different models. 4.1 makes it look very
wireframey. Uh 2.5 Pro has a interesting
design sense where it always looks
somewhat different and cloths on it
makes it always look like a blockchain
landing page. Uh if you make it wrong.
So, lots of gradients and dark and big
letters.
So, to kind of as we seven minutes. So
we have uh YOLO toolbox is your agent
mode. Um there's a new workspace flow
that's really interesting. So if you
want haven't tried it out yet. Um it can
also trip you off if you ask for
something a new app in an existing
project. Make make sure you if you hit
that voice dictation built in visual
context I might get to showing around.
So once it actually starts finishing it
will open up the page in browser preview
in VS Code and I can actually select
specific elements. And then the auto
accept option. There's another auto
accept after delay if you don't have
that on in VS Code is an autosave that I
really like to drive any live updates in
the background that are running. And the
undo and revert I quickly show up here.
If anything goes wrong, there's always
these buttons up here for undo and going
back. So, see where it is still
installing.
Beautiful Wi-Fi making demos easier. Um,
this how do you get console errors? like
that. Yes, actually when it when this is
runs and it runs any terminal commands
and the terminal commands fail, it will
actually look at the output. So if
there's any any dependencies missing, it
will go off and install them. It's still
like shad CN had some changes in how you
install it. For example, it will figure
out because the error messages use this
package instead and the next command
will use console.
Sometimes it run things in the
background terminal, but there's ongoing
fixes to make it basically always find
it. Okay, let's keep going. Um,
next one. While runs, um, it's use code.
So really try it out embrace the
exponentials to build that AI intuition
like what is AI good at what AI can't do
yet and find that for yourself just
baseline what AI can do and that's where
YOLO VIP coding with like a very open
canvas and being able to steer AI is
extremely powerful skill to inform all
of other AI usage then the second one is
user in frameworks I picked react invite
in my demo because it gives a nice
grounding and it's something that hasn't
changed in a while. So that's a good way
if you use any any new ones, you want to
be more explicit about how to read the
docs and where to find information. And
lastly, it's all about iteration. So
it's a whiteboard. You want to uh wipe
things off completely. You want to start
from scratch. You want to work on
specific items, but really about like
having this this iterative workflow
outlined.
Quick check in. Still working on some
files. Okay, we keep going.
So structure v coding and that's where
we bring in a template and that template
comes with a consistent text stack and
that could be your internal st could be
a container that you give to developers
or if you want to work on UX um bring
this template in and you can just start
vibing that could be even for
non-technical people just check out this
repo or work from this template on
GitHub open in VS Code engage agent mode
in voice mode and start vibing but
because it's a template It comes with
this consistent text stack and it comes
with instructions to guide uh the
copilot flow onto a specific conventions
that you're already running with. And
then lastly, we want a custom tools
using MCP and other things to make sure
if it needs information or needs more
context that can that get and that's
really more high more reliable and more
consistent than YOLO mode. If you ask
your mode and if it wouldn't have given
it material UI if it might have picked
any other design framework it might have
went with tailwind. So and that allows
you to internally we use fluent UI. So
you're going to use fluent UI this is
where you get the package and just it
it's outlined and it's clear and so it's
really great for bootstrapping these
screenfield projects because you end up
with something people can hand over to
engineering and engineering doesn't say
like this is totally not what we're
doing.
Um, and this thing also it's it's better
at the off mainstream like anything
that's non not popular like spring boot
whatever latest version you have that
the AI struggles with you can add more
instructions on top that it gets it
right more often.
Going to show a quick how does it look
like? Still vibing.
Yeah, I think it's mostly internet speed
here making it slow. So let's figure out
um this is a nice repos on the on the
internets. Um, if you go to github.coms
digital
and then I put it up I think it's still
under
front end vibes template. So let's zoom
in if you want to take a screenshot for
later
again. Yeah.
How's this screen sharing working? I
don't know. I'm not technical. Um, is
this entire screen right? So,
okay. Yeah, I think every time I switch
back to PowerPoint, it it tries to do
the multi screen again. Okay. So,
uh get up again. Git up again.
Sharing the vibes here. Two minutes.
Okay, we got good. Um yeah, so that's
template. Just going to do a quick round
up. So, one, we have chat modes. That's
what I'm highlighted here on the left.
GitHub
uh folder chat modes. And then you can
define already tools. You'd find what
what tools are in the mode and what's
the system prompt. Then they show up
down here. Actually, you can switch out
agent. It's a new agent that's now doing
test-driven development for you. And
that description here I wrote in another
demo earlier about how to do test-driven
development. I didn't know there's a red
green and and anything else. So that's
up to you how you define that mode. But
this basically now guides it. you have
to write tests first and then you write
code and it has to pass and only ask
only move to writing code after I
confirm because I want to review the
test and that's much easier for review
to me. Um you can also create prompts
and that's a way for your team to create
these reusable tasks that are then used
across different iterations. It could be
new landing page for your design team
like we need a new micro landing page
this is how you usually structure it and
then they can just create it. And
lastly, instructions. Those are new.
Those are githubinstructions.
And those can outline what specific
parts of the codebase do.
So to go back to the slides,
yeah, the thing again. So you want to
bring in workspace instructions. There's
a good document on VS code documentation
on customization. If you want to go
deeper, there's um the instructions
files I showed and prompts. You want to
make them dynamic for specific parts of
the codebase. And you want to start
bringing MCP. couldn't show up MCP right
now because we run out of time. Um,
check out my MCP talk from the MCP track
if you want to see some of those demos.
Um, also VS Code has access to problems
and tasks. So, if you have your task
runners set up in VS Code and your
llinters properly, it will actually
start fixing code as it makes mistakes,
which is a really powerful context to
have for the AI. And lastly, if you
haven't found that little spark icon in
your commit, it's really important once
you start working and having workable
code to keep committing the that
workable code so you don't get into
weird areas where it worked before and
now my VIP coding broke it and that's
always sad. So review is important.
Um always says on these instructions are
important start with errors. Committing
is important. So commit often pause the
agent to inspect.
Lastly, in 10 seconds, spec driven
really brings this often repeat idea
which shows you here as well. You start
with a spec, you make a plan and then
you implement the plan and that really
brings it up to the large scale. And the
features we have here, I showed off
prompts, more MCPS and more task
specific tools that you can bring in.
And we're up. Happy to chat more
outside.
[Music]